could make history.
What's in your wallet?
>> Tucker: WE ARE CONTINUING
OUR EXTENDED CONVERSATION WITH
CONGRESSMAN ERIC SWALWELL,
DEMOCRAT OF CALIFORNIA.
YOU'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT RUSSIA
BUT YOU ALSO BECOME KNOWN FOR
YOUR POSITION ON GUNS AND YOU
ARE ONE OF THE VERY FEW
DEMOCRATS I THINK WHO HAS BEEN
HONEST ABOUT THAT.
YOU SAY THAT THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
OUGHT TO BAN A CERTAIN SPECIES
OF RIFLE, YOU WROTE A PIECE
ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS NOT A SECRET OF    VIEW
THIS IS NOT A SECRET OF    VIEWO
HAVE.
IF YOU SAY THIS.
MILITARY STYLE SEMIAUTOMATIC
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
WE SHOULD BUY BACK SUCH WEAPONS
FROM ALL WHO CHOOSE TO ABIDE BY
THE LAW AND WE SHOULD CRIMINALLY
PROSECUTE ANY WHO CHOOSE TO DEFY
IT BY KEEPING THEIR WEAPONS.
SO WE SHOULD CONFISCATE?
>> THIS ENTIRE CLASS OF
FIREARMS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TRIED
TO DO THAT?
>> DID YOU READ THE OP-ED?
>> Tucker: I JUST QUOTED IT
EXTENSIVELY.
>> I'M NOT CALLING FOR
CONFISCATION GRID WE SHOULD
INVEST IN A BUYBACK.
RESTRICT ANY WEAPONS THAT AREN'T
BROUGHT BACK TO HER GUN CLUBS,
HUNTING CLUBS, SHOOTING RANGES.
KEEP THEM THERE WHERE IT'S SAFE,
NOT ON OUR STREETS, AND IF YOU
ARE CAUGHT, JUST LIKE IF YOU
WERE CAUGHT WITH DRUGS OR
ANYTHING ELSE, THEY HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE TO GO INTO YOUR
HOME AND YOU HAD ONE OF THESE
WEAPONS, I'M NEVER SUGGESTING
SENDING TROOPS OUT.
>> Tucker: CONGRESSMAN FROM
CALIFORNIA.
CAN YOU PUT THIS BACK ON THE
SCREEN PLEASE?
I'M GOING TO QUOTE ONCE AGAIN.
AND WE SHOULD BUY BACK THOSE
WEAPONS, AND I'M QUOTING,
CRIMINALLY PROSECUTE ANY WHO
REFUSE -- WOULD CHOOSE TO
DEFY IT BY KEEPING THEIR
WEAPONS."
IF YOU'RE GOING TO PROSECUTE
PEOPLE WHO DON'T GIVE UP THEIR
WEAPONS.
>> IF THEY ARE CAUGHT WITH THEM
DURING I'M NOT SENDING TROOPS
DOOR-TO-DOOR.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU THINK
WOULD HAPPEN?
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE LAW-ABIDING,
HAVE COMMITTED NO CRIME, NO
PLANS TO COMMIT A CRIME.
HE WOULD INSTANTLY TURN THEM
INTO FAMILIES.
DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD HAVE A
CIVIL WAR, ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
THAT?
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL HAPPEN
IF WE DO NOTHING?
WOULD DO YOU MARKETS WILL BE
KILLED?
MORE CHURCHES WILL LOSE
PARISHIONERS?
>> Tucker: I'M CRITIQUING YOUR
VERY SPECIFIC SUGGESTION, AND
YOU ARE A LAWMAKER SO THIS IS
MEANINGFUL, WHAT YOU SAID.
>> I TRUST THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE LAW-ABIDING, THAT THEIR
WEAPONS COULD BE BOUGHT BACK OR
KEEP THEM AT A GUN CLUB.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO GIVE IT UP BUT
>> Tucker: YOU'VE DONE NOTHING
WRONG, YOU HAVEN'T HEARD ANYBODY
AND YOU JUST MADE THEM INTO
FELONS.
>> THERE'S NO TROOP ROUND UP
HERE.
>> Tucker: YOU JUST MADE THEM
INTO FELONS.
YOU JUST SAID THAT IN THE PIECE.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP, YOU
WROTE THAT.
IF I'M A GUN OWNER AND I HAVE
ONE OF THE WEAPONS YOU SAY
SHOULD BE BANNED AND I DON'T
FEEL LIKE BRINGING IT TO A GUN
CLUB, I FEEL LIKE KEEPING IT IN
MY BEDROOM CLOSET.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU ARE GIVING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ONE OF
CREDIT THAT THEY WILL BE
LAW-ABIDING.
>> Tucker: THAT THEY WOULD
OBEY YOU.
>> I'M SUGGESTING WE HAVE A
CONVERSATION IN CONGRESS AND
PASS A BAND LIKE THIS.
IT WOULD HAVE TO BE PASSED BY A
MAJORITY.
>> Tucker: WOULD YOU APPLY
THESE STANDARDS TO YOURSELF?
>> I DON'T THINK OPS THOUGH.
>> Tucker: YOUR BODYGUARDS.
>> I DON'T HAVE BODYGUARDS.
>> Tucker: I WAS THERE TODAY.
>> I DON'T PERSONALLY HAVE
BODYGUARDS.
THEY ARE POLICE OFFICERS, THEY
ARE SWORN, THEY ARE TRAINED.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE THERE TO
PROTECT YOU.
>> I HAVE TWO BROTHERS WHO ARE
COPS, MY DAD WAS A COP.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO PROTECT ME,
I WANT THEM TO PROTECT THE
PEOPLE GETTING SHOT UP IN THE
SCHOOLS.
>> Tucker: THE POLICE TO
PROTECT YOU.
>> THIS ISN'T ABOUT CAPITOL
POLICE.
>> Tucker: IT IS THOUGH.
>> THIS IS ABOUT THE KIDS WHO
ARE DYING.
THEY ARE AFRAID TO GO TO SCHOOL.
THEY HEAR A BOOK DROPPED, THEY
THINK A SHOOTER IS WALKING INTO
THE CLASSROOM.
DON'T THEY DESERVE TO BE
PROTECTED?
>> SELECT PROTECT THEM.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE THEM IN
YOUR BUILDING WHERE YOU WORK.
>> DON'T DENIGRATE THE COPS.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT DENIGRATING
THEM.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY CARE MORE
THAN I DO, WE CARE THE SAME.
>> DO YOU THINK OPS SHOULD HAVE
GUNS?
>> Tucker: I THINK YOUR
BODYGUARDS HAVE THE SAME GUNS I
HAVE TO PROTECT MY FAMILY.
>> DON'T DENIGRATE THEM LIKE
THAT.
>> Tucker: IF HE COMES TO
PROTECT MY WIFE ON A NETWORK YOU
GO TO WORK --
>> PROTECTING THE CONSTITUENTS.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE PROTECTING
YOU ACTUALLY.
WHY SHOULDN'T MY WIFE HAVE THE
SAME FIREARM AT HOME THAT YOUR
BODYGUARDS USED TO PROTECT YOU?
>> THAT'S A RIDICULOUS ARGUMENT.
IT'S ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU ARE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN ME?
I'M ASKING IT SINCE YOUR
QUESTION.
WHY SHOULD YOU GO TO PROTECT
YOUR --
>> OUR COPS SHOULD NOT BE
OUTGUNNED.
PERIOD.
OUR MILITARY SHOULDN'T BE
OUTGUNNED.
>> Tucker: WHY DON'T WE JUST
LIMIT THEM TO THE SAME GUNS I
CAN HAVE AT HOME?
>> WHY CAN'T WE HAVE A REAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS?
>> Tucker: THIS IS A REAL
CONVERSATION.
>> YOU ARE CALLING COPS
BODYGUARDS, AND THAT'S
DISRESPECTFUL.
THEY WERE ALL HERE IN TOWN
HONORING THE FALLEN AND YOU ARE
CALLING THEM BODYGUARDS.
MY DAD WAS A COP, HE'S NOT A
BODYGUARD.
HE PROTECTS PEOPLE.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> Tucker: TO MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS HAVE BODYGUARDS?
>> THAT IS SO DISRESPECTFUL.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE.
THE GOVERNMENT PAYS FOR THEM.
>> THEY PROTECT YOU AND YOUR
KIDS AND OUR FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: CAN I GET THE SAME
IN MY OFFICE IN THE TEXT PAYERS
CAN PAY FOR IT?
CAN I ASK A QUESTION?
IF I WALKED ON THE OFFICE, GREAT
GUYS, I'M NOT ATTACKING THEM.
THEY ARE NOT UNDER ATTACK AT
ALL.
I'M MERELY SAYING THAT YOU HAVE
BETTER PROTECTION THAN I DO.
AND YOU ARE SAYING THAT MY
FAMILY DOESN'T DESERVE TO HAVE A
CERTAIN SPECIES OF WEAPON.
YOU GET TO DECIDE WHAT WE CAN
PROTECT OURSELVES WITH BUT YOU
ARE NOT GOING TO IN ANY WAY TAKE
THE ABILITY TO PROTECT YOU AWAY
FROM THE CAPITAL POLICE.
>> I'M SAYING EVERY POLICE
OFFICER IN AMERICA IS OUTGUNNED.
FOR THEIR SAFETY AND THE PEOPLE
THEY PROTECT THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
ASSAULT WEAPONS.
>> THE RULES DON'T APPLY TO YOU.